- I got an email from a
company called Lazarus 3D
offering to show me my
own internal organs,
not on a screen or visualization,
but by 3D printing
a full-size, realistic, and
heavy copy of my abdomen,
and cutting into it with
an actual surgical robot.
Now, this isn't going to be the version
with full realistic blood.
YouTube probably wouldn't like that.
But, if you're scared of surgery,
you might want to watch
through your fingers.
And also, this isn't an advert.
I paid for my own MRI scan
to get the data that they've worked with,
but I'm not exactly doing
a randomized controlled trial
here either.
The company wants to show off.
The case studies I've seen look solid,
but I am not qualified to
check medical claims.
I'm just a guy who's
about to watch someone
cut into a 3D printed copy
of my own guts.
- So our early studies indicate
that by performing rehearsals,
there can be clinical benefits,
but that's something that's
going to need to be borne out
as we perform more and more studies.
- Let's open it up.
- Let's do it.
- In every other human endeavor,
an ability to rehearse and practice,
and do so specifically for
that individual event,
has major payoffs.
So if we take the best
violin player in the world,
and we give them a
highly-complicated piece of music,
they're more likely to make a mistake
if they're sight-reading it,
than if they've had an
opportunity to rehearse.
- The crux of the problem
is that surgeons, unfortunately,
don't have a way to
learn outside of the OR.
- It is as heavy
as I am.
There we go.
- Whoa!
- Wow.
- We use both MRIs and CTs
and they can tell you different things.
So this process is called segmentation.
We end up with a 3D image of Tom's organs.
We send the "Digital Twin" to
the physician that orders it,
so that they can review
and approve that design,
and allow for production
to begin on that piece.
- I've never, ever taken
my shirt off on camera...
but that's me!
- That is you.
- I recognize that.
- So this is the upper
part of the abdomen.
This is your liver and
you can see your spleen here.
- That's sticky.
I kind of assumed that
'that' would feel like 'that',
and it doesn't. They've got
completely different textures.
- I mean it's the closest you're
going to get to a real abdomen.
- So they have artificially given
me a cyst on my left kidney --
on this thing's left kidney!
- That's correct.
- You're going to go in
and try and remove it.
- With your permission, I will.
- The camera gets inserted
by the technicians.
So for a patient who is
under robotic surgery,
they would have those
three ports inserted there
and then stitch it
back after?
- Yes, sir.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
So this is a depiction of
the left side of the abdomen,
and, as you can see here,
we have your kidney,
and you also have the collecting system,
which is depicted by this
yellow structure here,
and then you have the blue structure
which depicts the vein,
and the red structure
which depicts the artery.
- We originally made our models
more realistic in color,
so that they looked
more like real tissue,
but the feedback we got,
is part of what the surgeons wanted,
was to have clear demarcations.
This is very clearly
where this structure is,
and this is very clearly another.
- This is a skeletonized version
of what you would see in
an actual real setting.
Typically, there's a lot of what we call
intermediate stratum,
which actually exists
between the actual organs
in the vessels of the body,
and it's like connective tissues.
It involves fascia as well as fat.
- So every movement you make there
is copied at a tiny scale by the robot.
- That's correct. So we can scale this down
to one fifth of the human movement.
So one of the advantages of the robot
is that it allows the
surgeons to operate longer
into their six and seventh
decades of life, even.
If people have tremors, et cetera.
- You can't see this 'cause you're
looking at the machine,
but I just, kind of instinctively,
grabbed my own abdomen there.
Just, that's...
...that's in there.
That's me!
- That is you, you know.
- They've switched off
a few things, right?
So I don't have stomach
or intestines there,
and it's not bleeding everywhere.
- We do make models that bleed.
The most common thing we do
is have a hollow artery or vein system
that's filled with blood,
and when you make a cut,
you'll initially get a bleed
as it drains out of that system,
but then, because it's
not hooked up to pumps,
and all of this added complication,
it doesn't continue to bleed.
- What he did do, was he
made it a little interesting,
and he created what we call a renal cyst,
which is a thin-walled, fluid-filled sac.
He made this quite challenging for me
in that he positioned it
behind your vasculature,
and that's the lovely part
about being able to rehearse this
prior to the surgery.
- This is fascinating!
- You know, so as a person
is actually being positioned,
and put to sleep,
I'm actually doing a rehearsal.
So what it does,
is it helps me to fine tune
my visuospatial perception,
as well as be able to know
how to position my hand on the robot.
All of that stuff helps to
improve efficiency and accuracy
when you're actually doing the
real dissection of a kidney.
The difference with the robot,
unlike with a human hand,
you don't have tactile sensation.
So I don't, when I touch this,
I don't know how that really feels,
but I can look at the tissue
tension when I press here.
This is okay.
This is way too much.
- I know it's not a voodoo doll,
but you did that and something
in my guts went, ooh.
- [laughs]
- Oh!
- It's nice to have tissue that
pretty much acts like real tissue.
- With one of our collaborators,
they actually used a robotic arm
with a scalpel and a force sensor.
So we took animal tissue,
this was a pig kidney,
and this arm would make
a cut in that kidney,
and it would measure the
forces that are experienced
by that scalpel tip.
We could then do the exact
same thing to measure
and then we can iteratively
improve these materials
to make them behave like real tissue.
- All the 3D printing nerds
are going to be asking me,
how on earth they 3D printed
soft tissue like this
and they will not tell me.
- Unfortunately, that's a trade secret
and I cannot comment on that!
- This is the cyst itself,
and see how this tissue here,
this is like your peeling
layers of a grape.
- And that is a fluid-filled sac.
- Yes.
- They wouldn't show me how they've
3D printed a fluid-filled thing,
but they have.
You can see the little striations
where it's been laid down.
You can see the 3D printed parts.
- You sure can.
So I typically like to
remove it as one whole cyst,
but oftentimes this is not
infected fluid or cancerous,
you know, this is usually benign.
So it's more style points.
They're separating nicely here
but sometimes it's really adhered.
- Wow!
Oh. Oh, there we go.
- Oh. That's okay.
There we go.
That's fine.
- There we go.
This is, A, why surgeons rehearse,
and, B, that, I assume,
would not have been critical.
- No, no, not at all. No.
- For every procedure,
there are different things
that you need to be worried about.
Sometimes it's that a
structure you're operating on
is right next to a major vessel.
Sometimes it's that it's next to nerves.
Sometimes it's that
there's a time constraint,
because you have to clamp an artery
and, at that point, that
organ will stop getting oxygen
and you are in fact on a clock.
- Our goal is to help
surgeons reduce the risk,
reduce their challenges,
and empower them.
By empowering the surgeons,
we are also empowering the patients
because they know
that when their surgeon has
rehearsed ahead of the time,
they are operating with confidence.
- And that's it,
and it's coming out now.
- Yep. That's it, right there.
That's your cyst.
- Wow.
Okay. I don't know how I feel about this.
- Wow!
That's pretty nice, there.
This is perfect, you know.
- Thank you for removing my cyst.
- Oh, you're very welcome.
Thank you. Yeah.